speaking of human girlfriends yeah um
i'd love your advice in this direction
but you're you have an amazing
relationship with uh kalila yeah uh so
you two are very different so you host
the tiger brother podcast together but
there's there's real love there there's
a there's a real connection
what do you um what do you love most
about kalyala
let's talk about love bobby lee yeah
yeah i mean that's a really pretty deep
i've never really gone down this path um
we're gonna walk down that path together
holding hands
it's one of those things where
the first time i met her
[Music]
it was almost as if i had known her all
my life it was really weird you know i
mean there was a
a trust there you know i mean that was
just fundamentally there
that i could trust her
and that i could you know
when i look in the mirror
and i see all my character defects and
stuff
though a lot of those things aren't
necessarily things i want to share with
people because i don't want to be judged
or ridiculed
but with her
i felt comfortable showing those things
and i think she feels the same way about
her
and then secondly she's funny
you mean she made me laugh and and she's
hot
it's all you know i mean the perfect it
was like a perfect combination of things
you know i mean she
one night we were in bed and i forgot
what the joke was but she really made me
laugh one night it was she was living in
an apartment in long beach
and i cackled you know i mean and
generally
women don't make i mean not women i'm
dating comics do
um don't make me cackle in that way
and then um thirdly she has um
she's partly asian
so it's like
you know one time i dated a white girl
yeah and i invited her to koreatown oh
you're about to be a racist a little bit
okay yeah yeah
and
what i love about asian girls
is
they'll eat something first and ask what
it is after but white girls ask what it
is before what is this
right
but clyde was like would eat the eyeball
eat everything go what did i just eat i
like that
you know what i mean
so it's like and it reminds me of my mom
in that way in terms of like my mom
growing up just to
scare us
and freak us out we'd have a fish and
she would eat the eyeball first
to see a squirm and as a kid that you
thought was gross and weird and this and
that but it's like
you know when kalila does it it just
kind of like i don't just
make feet makes it makes me feel like at
home yeah in a weird way i don't know
it's a it's a little act of fearlessness
i like that yeah just put in your mouth
and figure it out
yeah that's what i like
and at the end of the day she also
out of all my girlfriends and uh this is
gonna sound
not strange but um hard to admit but
my career when i met kalila was in the
[ __ ] box
i could not get anything going and um
this is at the time where
ken jong who's a very good friend of
mine very talented was getting
everything
and i just remember going i can't even
get an audition like i can't i would go
on the road
lex and i would fill half the room
i just couldn't sell tickets and
when i met her i was just kind of like
maybe this is the i have to find love
and open up my
world in that way
and she was the first girlfriend that i
ever had that
looked at me and saw the potential
and she said
no this is not doesn't feel right you're
so funny
and you're so relevant to me
and this is what we're gonna do
and so
she started tiger belly
you know and then um
obviously i had the skill set to do it
um
but once tiger belly happened and then
andrew was like let's do bad friends and
then
now
things are great you know my career is
i'm too busy almost in a weird way you
know
and i feel like she had a lot to do with
like for instance
before i met her even if i would get an
audition i wouldn't go
because i just wouldn't get it in my
head i was like i'm not gonna get this
i've gone on a thousand of these and
they just never hire me but she was so i
just didn't go on on them for years
and then she was the first girlfriend
that said no
i don't care if you don't get it right i
just want you to be a [ __ ]
and i want you to walk through fear
and so she would drag me to these
[ __ ] things and i
for some reason would book them
you know i mean so
you know in that way i saw the potential
of what you could be but she loved you
for who you are already yes
but also loved you for the potential
that you could become
yeah and i'm lucky in that way you know
so on day one you could show her you
said you could show her your flaws to
her like you felt like you could be
fragile with her well i accidentally
farted yeah or day one on day one yeah
you know because i just i'm a fart
machine yeah and i have loose cheeks
yeah i like how you would for the
listeners he just swinged at me yeah
i have loose cheeks and um but not in a
gay way not a gateway no and i um i was
we're on a couch and we're talking and i
kind of adjusted my body i ripped one by
accident and she laughed you know i mean
it wasn't embarrassing you know and um
also have a little penis
i have a little penis and it's all
relative yes it's for little
but relative to an elephant
everybody's penis is little yeah but i'm
not an elephant i'm a human you know i
mean so relatively human it's very small
and so when she saw it you know i mean i
thought she was going to balk at it yeah
right
and she looked at it as if it was like
an orphan
like
you know like i wanna
you know if it's a lost child and i
wanna you know
you know take care of it yep
yeah cradle it cradle yeah
well you man you you haven't met anybody
like that
uh never met a girl never seen one of
them
i hear they're nice
when are when are the two you get
married
we don't know yet
yeah is that something you would like
yeah um this comes up sometimes you know
we're in couples counseling we're
dealing we're working on some issues
that we have sure every relationship
even my friendships have issues
and so we're working through some issues
and once we get to the end of it we'll
figure it out
you